jerry squeeze my hand if you could hear
me
all I know is how to be a brighter
there is nothing more sacred than story
out of that sound mr. Salinger
through the course of my fascinatingly
dull life I've always found fiction
we're truthful in reality I write short
stories have you been published you're
not the first wife that's left are can't
stand always flips and phony so what do
I do now you're a writer what do you
think you do now write another story and
then another one after that
how is writing a real profession I don't
know some cut out for this
maybe not are you willing to devote your
life to tell the story there's no harm
in dumbing it down once in a while
you're trying to be clever every page
which is doesn't feel real what makes
you think of anything to say to people
you can enraptured people no I just want
my writing to be truthful so the best
student I've ever had stay alive
war hero doesn't always get afraid
sometimes he bows his head off you got
to stick out these dry spells
I think Holden Caulfield is a novel no I
couldn't write a whole novel Holden
Caulfield deserves an entire book
people think it has a lot of problems I
just don't buy older he's old and
supposed to be crazy
they don't want to coverage I went to
war with these guys over this one if you
went to war with these guys I've thought
of all get killed I should be dead too I
shouldn't be here
kids at this book where we 3-2 pitch is
Normandy see we'd be alive if it wasn't
for this pocket
[Music]
you're holding company right
imagine the book that you would want to
read and then go write it
Oh
you